people have come up to me in the street
and like they they've been out
on a date with us and i don't have no
memory of it
one personality go out with one guy
another person i said go out with
another guy
when the guys found out it was like
you've been too timeliness
hi i'm kim nice to meet you
[Music]
what is your disorder my disorder is a
did
dissociative identity disorder same i
guess
characterized by more than one
personality state
i'd say it's one or two or more
personalities
and the personalities have got no memory
between them and they take over the body
how
long ago was you diagnosed um so i was
19 so
three years ago but even then my
psychiatrist didn't want to diagnose me
with it they said that it was
not a real thing didn't exist so they
just kind of diagnosed me with the
symptoms of it
you know you have alters you have
dissociation i
i was diagnosed 24 years ago wow
yeah so it's quite a long time at that
time it was quite um
rare it wasn't as popular as diagnosis
as it is today
and not many psychiatrists understood it
or had
any idea about it even now people don't
really
believe you but it wasn't until i was in
a friend group and they were going
you're doing stuff weird you're acting
weird and i'm going i don't remember
that
that was when i started to realize there
was something
wrong i guess so what happened before
you were diagnosed with me it was a lot
of losing time a lot of
um not remembering where i'd been what
happened
and lots of like who am i what's going
on where am
i i've always had that like lack of
memory and not knowing what's happening
from
like very early age so for me it just
felt normal
so i didn't see i had any problems um
losing time
i'd never known any different so yeah it
all just felt so normal and then
i was seeing a therapist who was a
specialist in the id
i hadn't been diagnosed i had phoned in
to say that i'm sorry i missed my
appointment could i reschedule and yet
somebody had been to the pool so yeah
and that's when they thought there's
something weird is happening here
how did you feel when you was diagnosed
scared
yeah yeah one of the things i've always
kind of had was the
the background chatter in the brain um
just the constant what seems like static
noise in the head you know of people
talking never been able to make out what
they're saying
but occasionally i'd get the odd
opinion from someone specific but never
enough to
have like a proper conversation with
them but they might be like no don't go
that way
or um stay away from that you know
i could maybe remember
briefly if they've gone somewhere
so if they've gone out the house i might
remember physically going outside
or if they've spoken to someone i might
vaguely remember who
but not what about or what they said or
anything like that it's kind of like
falling asleep that's what it feels like
to me that you couldn't remember what
you were thinking
what are the differences between your
personalities there's a lot
i guess there's a lot of differences
it's like saying what's the difference
between me and you
you know age skin color
weight height in what they feel like
they look like i guess
what they like what they enjoy some of
us have very
different um outward projections i guess
so like
they would walk differently and have a
different accent or voice
we have a boy who's 12
so he's very boisterous he's very like
he'll
be stomping around very masculine um but
he also
puts on a boy voice to make himself feel
more comfortable
as a boy you know as like a teenage boy
so does he realize that he's got the id
and he's
sharing the body yeah he recognized when
he sees them in the mirror he can see me
and he doesn't like that he doesn't like
that it's like a woman's body
you know he'll bind my chest he will put
my hair up or do things like that to
be as as far away from female as
possible
and similar with one of our littles she
doesn't like being viewed as a woman
so wants to look as much like a child as
possible so we'll
wear like baggy clothes like this so it
doesn't show any shape
to try and make themselves feel more
physically like them
as well mine don't seem to even
understand or
do that they um they just take
who they are they don't accept that
they've got the id
so they just think that they're just a
single
singleton on you know just one person if
they were hosts
i guess would they change things on the
body when there's the switch
it's very subtle other than the younger
personalities
and one who's very religious um and you
go on about
the bible a lot but our voices are
mainly the same
yeah other than mannerisms would be
different um and there'd be a gap in
memory of what's being talked about it's
like they've
not they don't exist i don't i don't get
any inkling they're there
other than things around the house um
and i'm in different places and i don't
know how i got there people have come up
to me in the street and
like they they've been out on a date
with us and i don't have no memory of it
in my younger days one personality go
out with one guy another person i said
go out with another guy
when the guys found out it was like
you've been too timeliness in the
younger days it was fun
yeah i don't feel as though it's me
being out of control
it's them in control of the body and
doing what
they want to do but i'd come into the
body and i'd be in a psychiatric
hospital
that would worry me you know what am i
doing here why am i here i should
shouldn't be here does it frighten you
like blacking out
it used to i believe
the id is from a severe
continuous abuse at a very young age
so i think it was a protection a bit
like mind over matter
that's not happening to me i'm not
suffering um
you know another personality has taken
taking it on
that's stronger what are some of your
triggers anything that would be
related to abuse a bible um
certain colours um
the oven showers water
you so there's a lot of different things
the only reason i know him is because
um you know somebody's been there with
me when they've handed me something
and i've switched yeah do you know your
triggers um
america is one of mine um i know
and i can't exactly expect people to not
talk about a whole country
how is living with did affected your
family
i definitely see my family less because
of it
someone in my family told me not to get
diagnosed with it because i wouldn't be
able to get jobs
and told me you know that's stupid once
i
kind of got my diagnosis i became
homeless
with my partner that was a
struggle trying to figure out what my
head was doing as well as where we were
living
um was hard lots of people don't believe
me
when i first say it you know if i was to
come out and say it
um yeah i don't really tend to tell
people unless i'm quite close with them
um but then by that point they've seen
me switch
and they've seen like without me knowing
you know
you um
how's it affected my family well i think
that probably the main person it
did affect was my daughter she was taken
away as soon as she was born
and said that you'd um she's going up
for adoption
so i think that was um
a quite a tough time i didn't understand
did so i didn't realize another
personality had done something that
actually got her section we had to fight
um to the high court to go back
she came back to us at four or five
months
um and we did bring her up
and we did prove them wrong and now
she's
22 i've got a first-class law degree
and i'm glad you got her back
for her the id is normal so
she doesn't know any different than
having a mum with the id
yeah and she recognized the other
personalities she
talked to him and
you know and she you know she's great so
i think i've been lucky
what advice would you give to someone
who has
just received a did diagnosis
just learn about your your parts learn
about your alters
and learn what they want and like and
and accept them all and you know just
not be
afraid of it i guess one of us can't
deal with having all the time
all the time so that's why we switch you
know
just gotta accept it because you know it
comes from somewhere i see did
as protecting the body yeah it's a
protection if we didn't have did
then we'd probably end up in a
psychiatric hospital
for the rest of our lives so i think it
was a protection we could have even been
dead you know the person hasn't got to
blame their self
no it's not their fault they're not
weird they're not a freak
there are other people out there the
people just want to
do their thing just want to live normal
lives
nice meeting yeah
i had this guy that kept wanting to come
in and see me and it was
silly amount of money it was pathetic
anyways come in i said yes no problem
they've gone into the room and he's he's
given me the money i've gone out put it
away gone back in
and there he is standing with his
trousers and his paints down
and these rubber gloves on